The answer is 14/3 which is
the same thing as 4 1/3 rooms.
To solve this, I first found a rate,
which is the rate that Taylor and
Grant can paint a room,
which is 2 rooms in 3 hours.
And I set that equivalent to another
rate, which is x rooms in 7 hours.
X because we don't know how many
rooms they can paint in 7 hours.
Again, notice that the numerators
have the same units,
they're both the number of rooms.
And the denominators have the same units
as well, they both are number of hours.
Next we cross multiply, so
I'll multiply 2 rooms by 7 hours, and
I'll set that equivalent to 3 hours
times x rooms 2 times 7 is 14 and
that's equivalent to 3 time x.
Divide both sides by 3 cross
out the 3 in the numerator and
the denominator here and
we're left with x equals 14/3.
[BLANK_AUDIO]